все за що мене намагалися судити не має
жодного відношення до корупції сталося
задовго до політики і було придбано за
законні доходи Я розумію все це як
піарну акцію з метою затьмарити яйця по
17 грн вони крім мільярди Міністерства
оборони хабарі команди Зеленського та
нескінченні скандали президентської
фракції І ще одне що вам належить знати
про роботу цього суду рішення суду
блогерів офісу президента отримали
раніше за мене і адвокатів прокурори
заявили на всю країну що я скорився суд
своїм рішенням визнав що злочину немає
суд повністю відкинув безглуздя
обґрунтування прокурорів щодо мети цього
неіснуючого злочину суд звільнив від
покарання але я все рівно піду до
апеляції через численні процесуальні
порушення подвійні стандарти і вибіркові
правосуддя які проявилися через бажання
зберегти обличчя провальній справі
прокурорів де один з ключових
прокурорських документів є російським і
невідомо де взявся а обвинувальний акт
був умисного специфікований і суд - це
не